hello everyone and welcome to the oven
carmichael show-- i am your host Evan
Carmichael I believe that hungry
entrepreneur's deserve help so I'm here
to talk to you today about your business
I'm gonna know what is keeping you up at
night I want to know what your
challenges are and I want to try to help
you out today now it's been a
frustrating week for me there's been a
lot of people who tried to waste my time
and I hate waste my time I'm going to
share some of those stories that's why
they give guys like me a talk show so I
can get things off my chest and talk to
you about it today we're going to talk
about how to stay away from negative
people how to get the frustrating task
off your plate how when you hire people
most of them will waste your time and
how to raise your standards and think
bigger let's talk about staying away
from negative people okay we have enough
negativity in our lives as business
owners there's enough problems that we
have to deal with on a daily basis you
guys know what I'm talking about but you
don't need any more negativity to bring
you down you want to surround yourself
with people and news and information and
resources that pull you up and uplift
you and motivate you and don't bring you
down a friend of mine last week sent me
a story about this Norwegian woman who
went to Dubai on a business trip I don't
know if you guys have heard this story
or not she goes to the x and and she
gets raped in a hotel and if that wasn't
bad enough she goes to the authorities
trying to do the right thing results she
gets thrown in jail because in Dubai
it's illegal to have sex outside of
marriage and the only way to prove rate
as if either the rapist come forward and
said hey I did this or for muslim men
witnessed it and report it like that was
going to happen in this case and I felt
so bad for this woman you know I have no
connection to her whatsoever but I felt
so bad can you imagine that happening to
you I just as if the rape wasn't bad
enough to then do be the one thrown in
jail like she did something wrong here
and blew my mind and it frustrated me
and and the rest of my the rest of my
afternoon was
distracted and ruined by this and I told
my friend still it's emery this stuff
anymore I don't want to know it's also
the same reason why don't watch the
nightly news anymore do I haven't for
maybe 10 years because most of the
information is depressing right it's all
the bad stuff that's happened in the
world as an entrepreneur at least for me
I choose to surround myself with people
who uplift me who give me motivation who
make me feel good because there's so
much negativity around us that it's hard
right it's hard to run the business
already I don't want any more negativity
in my life that I can't control now this
doesn't mean you turn a complete blind
eye okay there's going to be bad stuff
that happens in your business there's
going to be bad stuff to happen in your
life and to the friends and people
around you you have to pay attention to
that okay i'm not saying oh let's
imagine that the world is one big happy
place you have to respond the things
that impact you but the things that are
outside your control the people who you
have no relation to at least for me I
don't pay attention to it I try to
surround myself with resources and news
and information that motivate me and
lift me up and make me want to be better
not the ones that make me depressed and
get distracted and don't allow me to
focus on my business so hope you guys do
the same we have our first caller on the
line Courtney Courtney's with that
Courtney where are you from and how can
I help hi Evan how are you this is
courtney boy i am from Torrance
California how are you doing this
morning good welcome to the program
what's going on thank you okay well here
it is i own a company called looky-loo
lashes and it's basically backyard
beauty I started about three years ago
and it's the eyelash extension sad
that's going on right now but my
question is is that how do i turn a
backyard Beauty into basically the best
in in secret in torrance california i
want to expand my company I want people
to know that I'm pretty much the best
out there I mean there are
I lacks extensive businesses all around
the place right now these nail jobs
places in Beverly Hills you know that
are all doing this so-called big set of
extensions but they all do a horrible
job and everyone's doing like this
application designing type of work
application but not designing and I'm
constantly fixing people and my business
besides doing lashes we do other service
other services but I want to expand I
have seriously a small-knit of girls
that are beyond talented and hot and
gorgeous we are this little nook that
were so talented but we're just in this
one little backyard but we blast out
amazing business and it's something for
31 what is your pitch why are you so
great why am I so great yeah right out
my work my photograph I even took all
the verbiage off of my cards and I put a
mini portfolio on the back because when
it comes to beauty and when it comes to
eyelash extensions and when it comes to
anything that's a visual you can talk
all you want people want to see pictures
people want to see okay will you that's
really great but what is it let me see
this and my work straight out shows
amazing maybe how would i do someone
like me who's never heard of his
business well I know a little bit but
pretend I don't know anything why should
I be interested how do you turn this
right you got to convince the people who
don't know about this but this is
something special they need to get Dean
to know about it Elsa what's the pitch
to me which has no idea about this ok
well the pictures to you eyelash
extensions what exactly eyelash
extensions are they are feminine
semi-permanent synthetics so cares that
go on each individual lash and you
basically have these amazing eyelashes
that women spend hours in front of a
mirror just to try to make their eyes
beautiful and you don't have to use
mascara you don't have to use any kind
of makeup on the eyes and just have
beautiful eyes point for our today
they're waterproof you can go into a
lake you can swim you to do anything you
still have these fantastic eyes so
wisdom courage
you want to start with something painful
what's the pain that you're helping
solve the pain that I'm helping solve is
people going into these little nail
shots and putting this crap on their
eyes and gluing their lashes together
and then these women are losing their
eyelashes or itching they're frustrated
they're being told that oh this is the
way it is it's perfect it's wonderful
and then three days they're actually in
pain with clapping eyes this is what you
want to start with right okay this is a
message that speaks better to people
than just saying what it is that you do
at home and I want you to think bigger
like porn California is great but you
should be known beyond just pour in
California right Oh exactly what I'm not
done with my pitch wait a second here
what we're not done I'm just giving you
a little basis of what's going on right
now mine is eventually I want to be
looky loo mobile because I am so good
I'm this little here in secret but what
I want to do is I want to roll up in
some sort of fixed a motor home or mini
bus with my looky-loo laughs certified
gorgeous face girl wrapped all the way
around and then I'm traveling to other
peoples places and basically this mobile
salon I like salon with eyelashes we do
massages we do body pants basically what
you do is you step out of your house you
come into my mobile home we rock you we
get you ready you look hot you look
gorgeous and then you just go inside and
go get dressed and I want to be able to
roll up on a place here have my own
private place to you know for you know
my private customers and I want to be
everywhere I wonder I want to mobile it
and I want to key also have you know a
hidden place and then it is the first
thing I got to do is focus they spend a
lot of stuff happen without mobile unit
focus just on the lashes there's a pain
there right people meet this service
right start talking to people who have
businesses who can relate customers on
to you who've gone through those and
experience that pain well I they might
check it out copy of them right with it
their lashes are falling out exactly
you're going to fix it but the thing is
soo that I started in my kitchen I
started with maybe two customers a month
I
have now 37 a week that's great I have
done over 450 clients and I want I have
my five year plan that you know to be
incredibly successful and at two and a
half years I'm you know I'm past my
goals and I want to get even bigger and
my reputation of my talent has been
straight word of mouth I have not done
one ounce of advertising besides
Facebook and my web page and just
talking and talking and talking and
talking and that's the best way to build
your business the people are talking to
seeing good things about you that's the
best way to do it I would still try to
focus in the focus just on the lashes do
one thing be amazing at it and start
reaching out now because now you got to
grow but reaching out to people who can
potential for a new customers to you
instead of going out to individuals
which are one fail at a time now you're
talking to businesses I can refer
clients you on an ongoing basis okay so
great so now I started that I saw it is
word of mouth right now I have fun
salons that like me and then that
promote me that don't do eyelash
extensions and they say their clients
over to me how do we get bigger how do I
get bigger eyes with a little salt is
hostile I love you in the midst of all
that i'm reminiscing um well we got a
paedo speedo for right now what you go
out to keep going out for the businesses
introduce yourself get them to help the
most it's not just you going out after
individuals one of the time we are
talking about your business now we're
talking about getting the front critics
off your place we all have times that
we're doing on a regular basis that we
should not be doing you know what I'm
talking about and every time I've seen a
big leap forward in my business it's
been because I've taken a look at my
schedule being what i have left on my
place and eliminated the stuff that I
shouldn't be doing you either get rid of
a completely eliminated or you automate
it or you delegate it off to somebody
else and that frees up your time to
focus on the big picture items to grow
your business and also gives you more
energy makes you happier because you're
doing the things that you want to do I
recently found myself writing my
worksheet so the last week is writing
some worksheets to help entrepreneurs
you know fill these worksheets grow your
business
and I found myself doing the writing and
the designing and designing started to
get on me I started to get frustrated
and as a result that day I didn't get
any writing done because I was too busy
adjusting the font and making things
look nice moving pictures around and I
didn't get any writing done and for that
business nobody can do the writing but
me but other people can do the designing
and I got frustrated that I was doing
this work and I knew it was time for a
change when I'm getting frustrated with
doing a task it means i have to give it
up to somebody else and so called a
buddy of mine Jason was a great designer
and asked him he would take that over
for me he gave me a quote and we agreed
and now he's doing this design which is
awesome and I get to focus in on where I
add the most value to my business which
is actually creating the content and so
for your own business you have to think
the same way you've got to think about
where you're spending your time and is
it the best fit for your business or not
most of the stuff that you're doing
should not be done again you should
either eliminate it completely automated
to some software or web tools or
delegated a way to somebody else who can
do it better than you take that
frustration off your place make you feel
happier and again it's not only about
doing what you do best it's about giving
you the energy once you get the crap off
your plate it makes you feel so much
better and gives you more positive
energy to go out and build your business
and do the things that you need to do to
get your company up to the next step we
have Christina on the line Christina
where are you from and how can I help i
am from soco west virginia and i have a
question I've got a charity organization
called ladies whoever to zinc and the
last six months that we've been together
we've raised over eight hundred dollars
with the veterans a we've hosted many
charity events went down to the veteran
homes visited done a lot of things with
the veterans however I cannot get the
community involved whatsoever here I
have tried I've done PR work output is
in the paper about four times in six
months no one seems to be taking
interest and I just need help one how
would you go about getting the community
involved
but why should the community be involved
and it's not just a dirty organization
it's raining on me and my husband and um
we do everything we pay for everything
we do think however we need volunteers
we need people to you know get involved
with the trade events that we're doing
like we had a 1k hi he'll walk and
everyone that was signed up was in my
group like everybody actually came off
out of their pockets because no one in
the communities you wanted to do
anything it's like what what's the pitch
to the community like everybody's
community have busy lives right they all
have their jobs they all have their
stresses and family life why should they
work with your organization well right
now it's everything one hundred percent
goes the veterans everything we do is
for the veterans the veterans only and I
just really would like to push this to
get the veteran you know as much help as
possible my husband's a veteran I'm a
military wife and you know everything
we've used for the veterans and I would
like to you know maximize whatever we do
we could take it to the next level if we
had more help and the community more
involved in it just like the community
here they really don't care and I mean
that's going to happen right people have
busy lives they don't care about a lot
of things so you have to make them care
you have to give me a story that makes
me care and say I really want to help
this organization so what is it about
helping better expression your community
that should make me care like I said one
hundred percent goes to weave as of jun
we have days when you warrior project
over eight hundred dollars and we're
doing goodies like everything we do is
strictly for the veterans and we'd like
to get more people involved I just don't
know how to do that because like I said
people really don't seem to be taking
interest so what's missing and I think
you have a great mission this is this is
awesome and it changed all that more
people aren't getting involved in this
what's missing is the passionate element
so I know you love what you're doing and
you can tell that in your voice but to
make me care you have to tell me a story
that has an impact so tell me about
somebody who use help and how much your
involvement you're going to
has helped that person build a better
life for themselves well if you're going
on my wife no it's not just one person
in general we actually volunteer we did
a lot of volunteer work at the Veterans
Home in barboursville West Virginia and
we actually were going to host them
about hugs pretty soon and everything
but we went down there a couple months
ago and just seeing and my children are
small they range from seven to three and
they're very very involved and what we
do my children and that's one thing that
I you know I'm blessed to have the
opportunity to show my children you know
the positive things you could do in your
community anyway just seeing the
veterans faces light up when we came in
with the you know baked goods and the
same key card and the drivers the metal
turns out were getting started this was
good and it was rare for it yeah and
we've done that we've actually had an
article written with had several article
written about it we've actually had
newspapers go down to the veterans
homeless take pictures what time you do
to better tell your store and get the
message oh yeah that's like what I'm
trying to do i'm trying to get us more
out there like i plug everywhere I go I
have flyers in my car I thought like you
know fly and there's a brochure is in my
car and everywhere I go I'm just like
plugin and it's like a paper the time
I've spent hundreds of dollars worth of
printer ink just like hey bring the town
is like no one really you know pairs I
feel the desperation in your voice and
you really want this thing to take off
and you're a worker which is great that
means you have the chance to be
successful I really look at though what
message you're putting out because
that's that marketing will work done in
wires out and going to newspapers
getting stores will work but it depends
on what the message is but you have to
clearly have your message to find and
show how you're having an impact and why
you need people tell
it's starting off this piece is there
you know it it's just taking a while to
kind of get to you right it's like this
is my first business and the first six
months so it's kind of like kicking
often we've done pretty good for the
first six months so I can't complain
it's just like I'm trying to just get it
going it's like you know i'ma stay home
all my three kids plus the summer come
so they're all holes I'm going to do
this my husband's actually gone with the
military right now so it's like all me
you're really close you just need to get
that story down better think about what
the headline is on all the fires are
putting out and see is that something to
truly moving people to the side Nicki by
name has to move people to watch this
ottoman vessel to take action but you're
close they're closed keep working on it
I think you can do it I can't thank you
so much no problem if you want to
welcome back to the oven Carmichael show
we are talking about all things
entrepreneurship I want to talk about
hiring people when you hire people most
the people applying will waste your time
and it's frustrating if you want to grow
your business you have to get it beyond
yourself you can only do so much
yourself right there's only so many
hours in the day I don't know any
entrepreneur who can work twenty six
hours a day so it's all going to come
from being able to get people on your
team to help support you now when you're
hiring it's frustrating and you often
hire the wrong person it's very time
consuming and as a result a lot of
business owners say forget this I'm just
gonna do it all myself and you'll never
get to that next level if you keep doing
everything yourself but here's how I
hire I'm recently put it I put up a new
job for video editor thermochromic accom
is growing we need more people I hired a
video editor and for my application has
86 people who apply for now when I put
on application I make it one big ugly
nasty paragraph everything is in one
huge paragraph it's terrible to read and
the reason is I want people who are
detail-oriented and can pick out the
information that they need I'm not
always the most detail-oriented person
so I need people around me who are and
so it's one big ugly paragraph the
people who read that and they can't pull
out the information
apply and that's great you know I've
just saved time I don't want you to
apply you're not going to read that
paragraph be detail-oriented the next
thing I do quickly is our ask the
question in the middle of that paragraph
for the video one I wrote how many
YouTube subscribers do I have on my
channel please include this with your
application if you do not include the
answer to that question I will not read
your application and it's buried in the
middle of that huge paragraph so it's
not obvious of the 86 people who apply
for my job only 36 actually included
that answer that means 50 people apply
for the job without reading the job
description and it's so easy to apply
for a job right you just change your
name I'm a cover letter you clicks and
attach your resume you're good to go it
takes no time for them but it takes time
for you as a business owner 50 people
would have wasted my time if I didn't
ask that question and it took me five
minutes to read each resume quickly
there would have been almost five hours
of my time is gone hey I value my time I
hope you do too so you want people to
salt eliminate gotta focus on getting
people in we're going to help you read
the description and want to be knocked
apart of your business and I don't care
if you have the best resume the best
experience great references went to a
good school if you didn't answer that
question because you didn't read my ugly
job description then I'm not going to
talk to you I'm not going to let you
waste my time because you are not a
hard-working hustler and that's what I
want that's what you should want in your
business you need people who are going
to work or go to grind it out we're
going to be detail-oriented and read
everything that you put up don't allow
people to waste your time you need
hungry people who are going to work hard
to help you grow your business okay from
there what I do is I have people on a
trial job and I'll hire almost anybody
on my trial job well give them five
hours and if they see what you can do I
don't care where they came from I don't
care about their experience I'll hire
them for five hours the video want to
give them a test project
a sample video here edit this and I see
what comes back and I've hired some
people who look terrible on paper but
they are hardworking they are hot
filling they want that job and they
often get it so don't be fooled by what
a resume says because anybody can write
something down you want people who are
going to work hard for you from that
trial job I end up hiring the person who
I want to work with and I usually don't
waste my time reading the cover letter
but reading the resume because it's
mostly BS you cannot let people to your
time up especially when you're hiring
because you need to make good hiring
decision to help you grow your business
and not keep churning through people
first met the person of the person and
you're stuck not able to do anything to
get you to the next step we have Vadim
underline but Dean where you start and
how can I help hi Helen um we are from I
am from Staten Island New York and I
eternally have a health food store and
flash juice bar and we've been open
differ about it about a year and a half
now we're doing really well um both
consumers and stand out of New York we
got it really badly with Sandy no let
this phone that can but we can get
flooded out of our business around the
way because we're actually by the water
a lot of homes got destroyed and all
that so a lot of our customers basically
the left the area didn't come back or
just simply don't have money to come in
and spend on things that you suspended
under stroll at Zeus's cetera but one of
my main questions is what's the most
effective way for us to readd vert eyes
our store that is not true policy
because at this point in the game really
don't have a lot of money to work but
because of slow down what is special
about your store or will you fill a lot
of vitamins but I store is you have a
efo juice bar and we do a lot of juicing
do let a juice cleanses for customers so
we really appeal to that side of the
customer base okay so what I would love
for you to do is be able to turn your
store into a destination site and not
just rely on the people in your meeting
area
but for people who say he have you heard
about this or they do this and they'd be
willing to travel half an hour an hour
to get to you if it's so great and so
what can you do to make it that great
because if you say and we still vitamins
in with your juices stuff are going to
make me travel well uh I mean what do we
do that's great i mean i think the juice
cleansing is the main part i just like a
cup of juice we do specific juice
cleanses for customers if detoxes that
we prepare in store their organic oil
and all natural and we have our own
formulas that we use in our own
proprietary blend for that it's a really
popular and we've actually just recently
opened up a website called with.com and
as a kind of ties into the first and how
do we advertise both because what we
would like to do this for you send make
a destination site and also start
shipping to people and delivering in the
local area and to other states possibly
as well i love it you move online you
take over the world i'm throwing darts
we're all communicating your message
right so I got to know why your juices
your juice cleansing system is the best
in the world what is it about this
system that makes it I you already know
like people love them enough right they
do it we've had a strong base customer
base in the year in fremont reform on
we've been open and at these people like
the fact that we bear phoenix i could be
physically what we're doing ingredients
that we're using and faculty scientist
you lot of supplements and bottle that
just both be on a regular cup of juice
so if you look at all the juice cleanses
that or the websites that offer the same
kind of concept that we do don't fall
for that what Oh diluted with alkalized
water you know just space to fill out
the answers in the bot 100% juice every
single I think people can not really
that and that's what we had a strong
turnout prior to that kind of hit the
area did you have online sales before
then too or this is something here
you're trying to do no we did not
because business are going so poorly
they actually uh we were looking their
website force people are charged about
the point you know about ten fifteen
thousand dollar
to do it properly and we actually count
somebody who he done trust the base you
know course and done done pretty good
job at it so we're kind of rolling it
out over the last couple of weeks like
three weeks we just rolled out I think
it's a great idea I think it's something
that will help build your word of mouth
and I think if you approach media
organization with this pitch with the
right pitch then they'll talk about you
what in holding that message right you
got to educate people as water cleanse
juice cleanses a guy have no idea i've
never done a juice cleanse so what's the
benefit and why should it go to you you
got to hone that into like three
sentences that okay I understand forgive
me your best shot 30 holding em to show
on the spot like that okay on the spot
this is a live radio here we go all
right in front of all going people if
not three sentences on the spot I think
it just friends the button subscribe
this client the body in back to your
house and rebates to remove the toxins
that's pretty much the way I recommend
it to any client that comes into my door
okay and why it's you that comes over
anything else I gives the body a break
from actual digesting food solid foods
no matter how good or bad they are um
give the justice system a whole gang
stoppage let's the juice in a sense
power wash everything that's been
accumulating the body for a long long
time or over whatever three to tie music
not don't and they are it sounds like
you really know what you're talking
about i think you could play really well
in the media but it's working on that
message we started it but you got to go
home and make it better you're three
sentences so that when you go talk to
the media and you're talking to
customers they understand it and it's
easy for them to go talk about it as
well if when you tell me about your
product it should be easy for me to
remember what you said pass it on to
somebody else that okay all right I
appreciate it good luck no problem over
everybody who's listening it's so
important to get your message down I
have to be clearly communicable not only
to the person prodigy but allows them to
spread the word we're talking about all
things entrepreneurship and I want to
talk
raising your standards and thinking
bigger okay too many entrepreneurs you
know who you are think small and your
constant running on that treadmill
running running running you're not
getting anywhere you have to start
thinking bigger you have to start
raising your standards and going out to
those bigger deals now if you're just
getting started hearing startup based
you know you don't have enough money yet
to pay for your electricity bill then
far think small right get money in pay
your bills take care of your family but
if you're not if you're a supporter
survival you know you're not making a
huge you're not live in a glamorous life
but you're not worried about your
electricity bill you have to start
upping your game if you want to grow
your business I went to the Blue Jays
game on the weekend with a buddy of mine
John Jays lost again unfortunately what
is season anyway talk about negative
news so John asked me halfway through
the game have it weren't your advice on
this business problem having I want to
do a deal with this angel investor who
came to me and he's done tons of huge
deals and I want to get in with him and
he asked me for some help on a project
he's working on and I don't know if I
should go in as a equity partner or as a
commission or a straight-up consulting
theme and he asked what I would do I
told them John I hate doing consulting
work it's such a small game because
you're trading your time for money and
it's okay to start to build up your
business but to get beyond to get to
that next step you have to move beyond
consulting if you want to do a deal with
this guy if you want him to think of you
as a partner then you have to go in as a
partner if you go insane you're going to
trade your time for money then he's
hiring you you work for him he's never
going to think of you as that next level
part of rehab I would go in and say hey
mr. angel investor you know this feels
little small for me but I'll help you
out I'll give you some advice to help
you get here and either offer him to do
some kind of equity stake or just given
the free advice I get free advice all
the time and it always comes back to
help me some way you have to position
yourself as an expert and is willing to
do bigger deals and not constantly eat
yourself down and and do no time for
money deals and you're not charging
enough
okay I want you to start thinking about
the bigger game again if you're just
starting out then part you got to pay
your bills but uh I should get to that
survival point now you got to amp up
your game you have to think about the
bigger picture instead of making couple
thousand you're making hundreds of
thousands of beyond I want to get to
your calls we have time for one more
caller I've got Lucy on the line Lucy
where are you from and how can I help hi
um I'm from Florida welcome to the
program what's going on Lucy okay I have
the problem that i have opened dancing
school and I need more customer and lets
us general dancing it is actually cool
dancing so pole dancing all right what
got you into pole dancing oh it was
always like I always said that when I
was younger and it's just I don't know I
think I'll it's awesome when women do it
at its heart well I've now so what's
your story what got you interested in it
so you did when you were younger what
optic why why do you keep doing it now
why am i doing is now yes oh why do you
want to start this business oh if I want
to have other girls to learn how it is
how to do that and it's art and if you
know they can also buy other boyfriends
you're saying you know for surprises oh
I'm your problem now is you need to get
more business in here into your company
alright so I'm an investor in a dance
company here in Toronto it means they
dance salsa we have now five thousand
people every year learn to dance also to
our school and a little bit about your
business maybe not the pole dancing part
of it I've never done pulled it but hey
might want to try to become trying to
let me know ah these types of classes
work great you have to get somebody in
at the beginning right if somebody comes
once i'm in love with people get hoping
to come back and back and back a bar
right exactly so the key is how do I get
them just experiencing the first time
because if they do that in the feel
empowered right at the beginning to come
in nervous they don't know what they're
doing
feel a little scared but you help them
feel empowered they have fun you know
they're staying active the kids got
somethin to experience that first class
exactly come just come to that one class
what are you doing there um it's Emma
advertise fitness fitness pole dance for
the troll so follow Joseph's who wants
two ways and took it in shade and have
fun with it do you offer any kind of
discount on the first boss that they
come in doors every first five yes I do
I have taxes and so what's up first buck
what's the offer for the first car okay
either one class for ten dollars try it
off or like a four classes coupon for
fifty dollars so and you know the more
classes they wanna come or four
obviously they get a better deal I don't
have out there one classes town long ten
dollars before classes is fifty dollars
yes it doesn't make sense I'm paying
more for four classes and 41 for the
beginning just for you know the trial
okay but on time you're going in yes I
try to make it free you know if you have
the thing with your business is there's
no there's no marginal cost all your
costs are fixed hmm so you just need to
get to get somebody in the door naughty
becoming the experience your first class
they have a great experience are going
to sign up and do more with you how many
this play it's free auto fence three out
of ten yes you got to bump that rate up
yes well guess we'll get six to seven
out of ten you have to make them make
that first class who / 5 not worry so
much about the technique but makes them
have a great time I want to come back so
as an example in our school salsa dancer
is really hard to learn takes a lot of
time
we do when you teach him another dance
in the first class called merengue which
is super easy to learn when people come
to get confident they learn some moves
and then they want to sign up and do
more but think about your own class what
you can do to make it super easy and fun
and not worth much about the technique
that they go home and say this is
awesome I got to go through this again
mmhmm yeah okay there's something you
handed I can help there yeah I see the
problem right there yet ok good luck i'm
on every two weeks if you want to call
back and let me know how you're doing
i'd love to hear from you yeah sure
thank you so much no problem so for any
kind of business if you have this repeat
business opportunities like you do in
dance classes then you need to make that
first experience super low risk to
either free or really low cost or you
need to find a way to make that first
experience so much fun and so great and
have so much overwhelming value that
they want to come back over and over and
over Hills forecast I see ya for Ernie
up at our our it's been so much fun
thank you everybody you want to learn
more you can fire me on my website I'm
www Evan Carmichael calm we'll be back
here in two weeks I look forward to
hearing from you soon have a great
couple weeks guys and we'll see you in
two weeks